Theo Tien ngày 6,5 mồ tên áng các biển pháp trường pháp mới của Mỹ là hành động khíu khách và thủ đệ.
Đông thời Tien Bù sẽ còn những phản tương sân nếu Washington tiếp tục giả tăng sức đẹp.
Bình yếu khẳng định những lệ trường pháp không thể kênh nước này phải đam phán và cho rằng Washington đang đi theo kịch bản thân bại gú,
không thể thấy đổi cảnh tân trên lược lối bên.
Một quan trích thúc cao của buộc ngoài rao trường tiền cho mạnh,
cô hội để Mỹ đặt lượng thế trong quá thể bị trường tiền bằng trường pháp là bằng không.
Thế Mỹ trực lối tiền bố á đặt trường pháp với tâm cai nhân và 2 tổ chức bị gáo vụ tham gia các hoạt động dở tiền và tấn công mạng giằm tài trở cho trường hành động trường tiền.
Bố tại chính Mỹ cho biết, mình pháp này nhằm ngăn chạng của một pháp phục vụ phát triển vụ khí,
đông thời duy trình sách gây xử kép tổ đa để vụ bây dưỡng từ bỏ trường hành động.
Trong khi đó, các quan tịch bảo hành cuốn nhận định vẫn còn khả năng Mỹ và trường tiền lối lại đầm phản cấp cao vào đổ năm tới.
Tổ thổ đúng là trăm trong chuyến tham trường hả tháng trước cũng tựng tiền lối sả xả ngập lại nhé lệnh đạo Kim Trân Ín khi điều kiện phu hợp,
mở ra hi vọng đối thoại dù có thả hải bên vẫn chưa hành yet.